Now we're going to use this in our blind signature scheme.
Alice will create a hundred messages like this, each one with a different random nonce.
But what she's going to add to the messages is an identity list made up of m of these values.
We'll talk more about what these are in a second as well as the usual value of the bill.
What we want these i values to be are things that reveal Alice's identity,
if someone knows enough about them, but otherwise reveal nothing.
Here's what they are.  They are a concatenation of two hash values.
H is a cryptographic hash function where the property we want is
where the two parts XORed gives you Alice's identity, and it's easy to create these values.
We can set the first one to a random bitstring,
and we send the second one to Alice's identity XORed with the random bitstring.
Which of these would be the minimum amount of information
needed by the bank to verify these messages?
All would be enough to learn Alice's identity if someone had both parts.